coming to you in five four three two
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast live
hit me with the sound board early on did
someone else do that or was that all me
because there was like a second one I
went for the same sound effect at the
same time what weird for sanitizers
sounds arrested me today's episode is
sponsored by stitch fix honey hems
policy genius and today I'm honored and
blessed and privileged to have with us
today be Theo von the Rat King Hey
good to be here man thank you it's
beautiful in here yeah I'm a I'm a I'm a
big fan I think you're one of the
funniest dudes possibly ever to grace
this God's green planet I have to tell
you when we saw you at The Comedy Store
we were there recently mm-hmm man when
you came up to the stage
you got the loudest response do you
think so I'm sure of it people were
going [ __ ] apeshit yeah and I had
seen you before
apes actually they were a that was on
acid and you weren't there at all but
thank you though sorry I don't receive
compliments well obviously I had to
deflect yeah and I have awkward I have I
have problems accepting compliments -
isn't that weird yeah something I need
to work on what is it because it's yeah
that makes me then you feel
uncomfortable because then you feel like
yeah now the person feels like I don't
even care about the fact that they call
me you don't they're being gracious
they're giving you a gift it's like if
someone's like hey man I got you these
really cool shoes bro I don't need shoes
[Laughter]
so yeah but I think that's there well I
think what I've learned to do and that's
a really good question it is is that you
just you don't have to accept the
compliment in your brain but you should
out of grace make the exchange not
awkward so you say thank you I did them
at numbers and that's what I can't be
like let me tell you something okay but
my natural inclination is to be like if
someone's like hey you're really funny
and it's like well you know yeah not
everybody you know it's like well
you're one of the few say yeah thank you
that's what I usually say thank you
that's nice you to say but sometimes I
will feel uncomfortable and I'll have to
react or off to try and make them feel
good also I think mmm Dan that's a dope
shirt yeah it's like just a normal Nike
shirt yeah I didn't have a shirt at the
end of this at the end of this episode
is just going to be me waking up from a
dream is that real
anyway they're all thank you for having
me yeah you you really are such a funny
guy and let me tell you guys after
watching this you're gonna want to go
don't don't let don't listen to me let
him convince you throughout the show now
the pressures on Fox I should have said
that oh yeah
well I was born under pressure man you
know I'm [ __ ] mom more tight pants
yeah yeah so and she always has and she
did even during birth right can you
imagine that Trinity oh they cut off
yeah they cut you I mean do you're
trying to gestate in there and you're
rocking against a 19 inch belt yeah so
you're so no so then in that case since
he is comfortable under pressure dark
art store deal Vaughn calm get tickets
you're on tour right now right yep on
tour right now we're gonna be in San
Jose this weekend and then Phoenix and
gonna go to Australia oh yeah yeah yeah
we have Australian fans so eight the
best fans man there's sweet-ass some
other efforts there I've never been but
I keep telling the boat over and see a
show that's what I tell them boat over
but you're going over there too though
yeah well they like I've been waiting my
yeah I've been waiting in Santa Monica a
zero but ya know I'm excited it's gonna
be crazy and then what else here we got
some other places Kansas City another
few places coming up hit the website
theof on Comm
he's also the host of his very own
podcast which is hilarious this past
weekend and no offense on Netflix yeah
we got not on Netflix yeah so god bless
all that going on for you Thank You Man
that's nice need to say so also an first
of all happy birthday to you yesterday
was your birthday right it was yeah it
was man had a lot of cake and got sugar
sick a little bit around
p.m. and uh that was pretty much it that
was it huh yes I keepin it slim yeah
kept ya have it slim man just really my
mom sent me a cake and I just started
eating and I knew I should need it right
when I saw it I said don't eat it mmm
and then I started eating it you saw it
what you solo it okay
I didn't know no I had about a third Oh
a third wow that's impressive
that's be smug it is and it's not safe
but it's your birthday that's true yeah
what kind of cake was it it was all
chocolate chip cookie cake oh yeah it's
my favorite so it was good but yeah I
appreciate the well-wishes man happy to
be born that's the start bro yeah you
know sex you got to be born and yeah get
getting a lot of time to you know try
not to murder somebody and they you know
that started really optimistic and that
took a turn oh yeah that's how it is man
you seem like a positive guy you seem
like you're always focused on positive
on positive you're trying to stay
positive because I know your story is a
somewhat you know Herald harrowing I
don't know yeah but like not not the
happiest upbringing right yeah
and so yeah one thing I've noticed just
like I feel like you true you have this
earnest attempt to really be positive
about things and I'm envious of that I
feel like I'm such a naturally cynical
good and I like that about you well it's
nice you to say that man it's another
compliment appreciate it man I'm left to
think of some yeah you better I'm
waiting well I like you know it makes me
sad if people don't feel good you know
is I think a lot of times when I was
young I just didn't feel good and I
didn't know why and I'd sometimes I
didn't even know I just thought that
that was the world you know that this
the world you just don't feel good in it
and then I realized that it's not
supposed to really be that way and and I
realized that at a late age you know
even just in the past couple years Wow
so yeah I think that you know I want to
yeah it just makes me sad if people are
feeling bad and they and they don't
realize that the world can be a little
bit different you know that's one of
these things that I kind of realized and
through therapy too is like you only
know what you know which is seems so
obvious but like if your parents suck
ass yeah
and you're like oh well yeah my parents
come home at 12 o'clock every night and
I don't see them and that's just ever
and that's just the way it is and then
you go to and then you go talk to a
therapist or you go to a friend's house
someday and they're like [ __ ] like
having a conversation yeah their dad
like what's go with the hell yeah so
like your dad's a while yeah what we
talk about yeah they're eating olives
together in the afternoon oh yeah but
yes this is different if you think yeah
if you grow up in everybody's juggling
and then you know yeah then you just
always just you know maybe we're both
hit in the head by balls you know oh wow
you were going about that was dude but
yeah but you're like then you're out in
the world and everybody else is like
dude what are you looking up in the air
for all the time I'm scared
that's a really good analogy is it
because everyone's just damn in the
world of jugglers yeah one man put down
the balls Wow you're from you're from
Louisiana nationally right yeah I'm from
Louisiana so it's a good state of you
guys been there know I'm such a poorly
traveled dude mm-hmm
I mean I'm from SoCal I know you have
opinion about LA mmm-hmm so I realized
ever pinyon about Hollywood I think
right that's how I've realized even
recently I totally agree and I don't
have an opinion as much about LA you
even get if I just because there's so
many great people like you going like JK
news you familiar with those guys yes
and you go and you're like oh these are
out this is LA and these this is amazing
the vibe over there and the people
having fun and the energy is great and
and I'm like oh this is different than
Hollywood yeah that's what I've learned
that's that's right I'm glad to hear you
say that
not that I care about LA or anything no
but it's so true you hear that all the
time and and they like I hate LA mm-hmm
kind of thing and if you if you're step
in Hollywood it's a night I hate it too
I can't fight a man with a needle like
trying to stab you yeah there's the
create
oh you can catch an H eye on a couple of
corners there yeah you know yeah yeah
but but it's so much bigger than that
yeah L is a huge city right like I never
lived in Hollywood but I always lived in
like the valley like around where we are
now mm-hmm
and it's nice it's there's a nice little
suburb you know but how do you how do
you compare to back back home Louisiana
let me think I'll compare it well how do
you like it here I don't well the
traffic makes things tough obvious
because you don't get to spend time with
people and I grew up in a place like
Louisiana and they're number one New
Orleans their number one thing is
tourism
so handshake and touching people putting
your hand on somebody's back while
they're vomiting you know I'm saying
natural empathic you know touches mm-hm
you know so you know to go from tourism
where it's like people spending time
eating listening to music being in that
environment people playing outdoors and
more relaxed we're here where every side
street turns into a highway you know
it's like that's true do you'll be yeah
like there's three lane alleys here
that's true this is us on HIV Lane in a
back alley the other day like Jesus it's
crazy yeah so just the fact that there's
so many people trying to get around and
it makes it hard to actually be people
and then I start to feel by myself
because I'm not being a person and I'm
not getting a reflection of myself off
others so sometimes for me a lot I would
learn about Who I am off of other
people's or other people were feeling
okay then I would feel okay if somebody
smiled at me and be like oh I must be
making somebody smile or being a part of
a smile so then you know when you don't
get that and you for somebody like me
anyway when you don't get that in your
in your car a lot or you're by yourself
you don't get the reflection to know how
you're behaving and then in my mind I
would start thinking that I'm behaving
bad or that I'm a bad person and then I
get stuck in myself so for somebody like
me it was tough to be in a place like
this at first and you've learned to kind
of find your your own space here yeah by
the time the past couple years have
gotten a lot better that's good
yep meeting more regular people even
podcasting in a lot of ways knowing that
have a conversation to go to you know
and meeting other people and just
dude even in our conversation in LA was
this that's why podcasting broke out cuz
nobody was having the easy yeah yeah
totally there's just people driving by
with an angry lawyer back yeah no I
think that's so true sometimes I did I
have the same thing I'll sit in my house
all day and I can't I like it forces me
to have a conversation yeah one that I
probably wouldn't normally have like how
often do you sit down like and so
intensely talk to anybody ready you do
your you're more interesting guy than I
am I feel like no I think I'm warm at
the Comedy Store more and so you have
max a home yeah
so you have your your that's nice
because you get to see people let's have
some you know bigger conversations not
that much I see it real tired during
conversations you know I mean when I was
yeah
I'm really I'm that guy you know I'll
take a break you're in a conversation
I'll come back in a little bit you know
because this conversations are real hard
you know sometimes you get into you know
the 40th minute of a conversation do you
know what's going I don't think I've
ever had a 40 minute conversation with
anybody outside of a professional
setting Wow maybe I mean with you
obviously that's granted but like but
like with a friend where you just sit
and taught like talk about something I
don't know yeah I don't get taught in a
way I don't get taught right I'm up I'm
a bad communicator I feel like I have a
trouble connecting with people do you
yeah do you feel like you do or do you
think you actually do because those can
be two different things so I think I'm
really good at connecting with people
our feet just touched me yeah you saw
that that I wasn't sure if I was a
special when I was an accident
and I'm coming I'm sinking back over
there oh that's eel magnetism I feel
like I'm good at making that first kind
of like superficial being like hey yeah
[Laughter]
cuz I feel like my dad is like the most
superficial dude on the planet earth
like he's made of like tinfoil oh really
yeah what do you think it came from like
a way he had to be or something like
that like was there a reason why
I'm sorry we're gonna go that's like the
black hole trying to analyze my dad dude
is it yeah Wow well he yeah there he he
was his his background is super weird
like his biological father was like a
famous movie producer and that when he
was like 5 years old his own dad
[ __ ] disowned him mm-hmm
because they got divorced this is the
crazy [ __ ] I can't imagine how [ __ ]
those make they got divorced mm-hmm and
then my grandma went and married a new
guy who adopted him but the biological
dad never spoke to him again he started
a new family and never [ __ ] spoke to
my dad again it even till the day he
died he passed away that's crazy yeah
and he wasn't like a he wasn't like a
toddler I mean while toddlers bad it
wasn't a newborn oh yes I've crucial 8su
for that to happen I would feel like you
know and then dad's just gone and you
never see or hear from him yeah but you
hear about his work probably oh yeah he
was saw her envious because they were
like wealthy and uh and famous and my
dad he kind of fetishizes wealth and
fame what it was it's therapy but my
feet now no it's just this is good
though this is good progress for me you
know I learned recently that when
something happens to a kid like a child
you know they live in a world where they
think the world revolves around them
they don't really know that other people
have or in the world as well they know
they're there but that that it's their
world together and so when something
happens that they reflect a lot of it is
their fault
some reason they did something why this
is you know so yeah I came and imagined
that that kind of like what that would
be like in your head I don't think he
ever learned the thing is I there's a
lot of things for me to be angry at my
dad about but most of all you have to
kind of always remember people are the
way they are for a reason
my dad never learned what it meant to be
a father or what it meant to set my dad
being a dad meant oh I don't even care
about my
don't even know he exists right I'm
gonna I'm gonna go die and not even
reach out you know my mom told me a
story that when Jessica was born the
first of our family she called his
biological dad and was like hey we're
having a kid you should call your you
should call Gary and say congratulations
and he never [ __ ] did you believe
that [ __ ]
Wow what a nightmare well that issues
are the craziest do you not care that's
weird
Wow a real token too when a baby comes
in because that's like another
opportunity for grandparents and parents
to make amends usually a lot of times
you know it's like you get out of jail
that's very baby right in a weird way
that's true that's a really good point
man that's so wild man or you do you're
doing your dad can y'all talk about that
kind of stuff for you guys keep things
more chill well so my dad you know my
parents are together and he's always
been a part of my life but he's like
like I said he's like he's he's like a
dude under a ghost sheet but there's
actually just not a person there like a
sheet like he watched TV he'll watch TV
all day Wow he plans his day around
what's on television
it sounds up yeah yeah but oh way is
coming back out so it does sound that
part so he was like you're dead so stick
and that's the probable and but but so
circle back my dad his he's a Salesman
run by nature and he's very good at
making that superficial connection with
me more like hey I'm Gary Klein you ever
known you know but underneath it it's
not even gilded because there's got to
be a little gold on top I say tinfoil
interesting wow man I suggested a little
[ __ ]
it's a vicious trap maybe that's his
must have a person he was as he was able
to develop yes yeah it may be in the
like it's you know like maybe it was
hard for even a him to develop that that
outer layer absolutely that is yeah man
I totally and so that again I bet the
baby will help I hope so I mean I bet it
could in some ways that you may never
even see you know our
don't know but like I couldn't stand my
sister you know and uh and then she had
a baby and like I just could stand her
you know and I could stand her and then
uh it just helped me learn to look at
women differently just I don't know and
I never expected anything like that I
didn't really care you know I didn't
have any sense of family and then it
kind of changed a lot of our family or
hold on hold a lot of our family so yeah
maybe that could be something that could
be cool yeah you know my sister had a
baby the first time my dad was always
like the hardest guy toughest guy like
he wouldn't even really show affection
at all he's just kind of like tough all
the time and then when she had a baby
Olson it was like sweet Whitman baby and
like we saw sides we never saw probably
since probably since you were a little
yeah yeah which is the magic I think of
having kids because what I'm excited
about about fatherhood is that like you
have this magical opportunity to see
your own self again
from that different vantage point yeah
and so you get to reframe your whole
life in a way that makes it makes way
more sense because you see yourself
you're like oh yeah oh that's what I was
like when I was five yeah do you think
back to like embarrassing [ __ ] you did
when you were like let's say 12 or you I
have this problem I'll be elected to it
I can't believe I did that but in your
mind you're thinking back as an adult
you see a 30 year old dude in a 12 but
then you see yourself as a 12 year old
be like how could I blame myself for
what I did this 12 year old is [ __ ]
barely sentient yeah
the social just eight nine involved in
the carport yeah how could I think that
at that age I'm having new anything it's
been that's funny I never thought about
that yeah we take this adult brain and
put it back into a child's behavior and
then feel bad about it for act in a
certain way yeah man yeah I think I do
that a lot probably yeah so I don't know
I've been thinking a lot about
fatherhood is a trip man a time elided
yeah a little bit
yeah he told me that I just got such a I
feel so excited for you guys that's cool
that's brave yeah not brave you just
[ __ ] squirt it did everyone [ __ ]
out babies oh did I used to work at a
donut shop bra when I was growing up man
and and dude we would always make sexual
jokes and me filling up no nuts dude you
know oh yeah oh here's Todd a little bit
of raspberry in there you know trip me
out another thing about childbirth we
tried for like two years
[ __ ] there's like a billion and
a 1.5 billion people in India
what are they why am i why is it so hard
for me to have a baby but there's like
10 billion people in China
you got a cook you got it alone they
can't stop and here we are obscene
doctors humping yeah get that curry Lube
thing you got to do something man you
know put a little it's that Rhino to us
yeah George draw a little law what's
that elephant that pushes all the
obstacles out of the way don't mail
Gargamel no not Dumbo dangle adesh I
think gang love - dude you got to get a
gangly - that's you on your hip yeah all
right
oh you were oh gee because I'm saying
yeah he makes good sperm they say you
know elephant can make almost like 7
quarts of sperm how much is that with
your hands can you show me because I
don't yeah I can show you you know I
love I can't visualize ounces you can't
I can't
well how much is one ounce Oh 1 ounce is
probably off this much in a cup that's
about this big you're [ __ ] and on it
I love little amounts what's your
favorite little um I would probably say
a graham but a wet graham a wet grant
yeah because it's that is smaller than
then it appears yeah Graham anybody
could do that a wet graham you'll get
like a fancier element or something yeah
you know like mercury
yeah you know you could get a wet
grandma mercury do it are you
what's up Wyatt you're like educated all
the sudden with chemistry and [ __ ]
talking about every mercury telly every
elements no yeah you know I'm not trying
to give you that idea
oh no I know but like you're just that's
pretty impressive
oh no man I just like you small amounts
no I've always we had a bunch of I
remember for Christmas one year I got a
bunch of little cups and stuff and we
would love doing that kind of stuff you
know just having small amounts of this
or you know small amounts of that you
know I love that kind of stuff yeah
another world you're a chemist and
another life
well the periodic table speaking of
semen man we had always thought SEMA
should be on the periodic table you know
is the [ __ ] grandfather as the ball
of the real element of life boron bro
talk about nut to Boron's for hos like
the periodic table cheers from out ain't
Stein iam oh what's this a rock of I'm
Stein iam in my backyard and I think
that maybe Israeli propaganda dude yes
Don iam what is it dude long hair
haven't slept much wearing women food he
does that you wore one MIDI really yeah
I could see that being fun for him he's
just a wacky dude he's like dude black
holes women shoes [ __ ] like crazy by the
way did he really was a womanizer he
[ __ ] like crazy he's like he's like MC
swear my yeah Einstein what was his
first name Lawrence number Albert
Lawrence he would've never become
anything if his name was Larry Einstein
Einstein man that guy's not famous at
all
that guy's smarter than [ __ ]
nobody will [ __ ] who is his brother did
I bet his brother was a real [ __ ] yeah
who went to sleepaway camp years after
he was too old to be there yeah
like damn if you're 17 brother 9 wait
ice that's kind of a dope name can you
can you be Einstein today are you know
what you're gonna be [ __ ] for a life
because that's a bad comparison to set
yourself up for like oh I nine over here
right but it's a dope name it is a good
name but if they but yeah he ruined it
by being too dope today for Hitler
ruined it by being too andö the under
that's the best way to establish a bond
he wins it yeah man those are dark
artists right there all of them really
and I sign I think is too because you
know to be playing around in women's
shoes with electricity or [ __ ] at the
house bro when there's no fire
department's back then I think you may
be thinking of uh you gotta be really
you gotta be kind of cruel of the middle
you gotta have a cruel caramel Center
well nothing's darker than a black hole
and that's what he predicted did he
really in the end in his theory of
relativity predicted black holes and he
he did the mash he crunched the numbers
and he's like according to this theory
and I'm the most brilliant guy alive so
according to this theory there's black
holes and he's like but this is such so
strange that this could exist that my
theory must be wrong
Wow and he died before they found actual
black holes but he in his math and in
his imagination he was like this thing
is so [ __ ] weird that this could
exist that this theory is wrong isn't
that crazy
that's like having such an imagination
coupled with such a just like the
ability to like the facts the figures
and just that's fascinating just to have
both of those things and that severe I
love learning about him he was he was
like one in a billion I mean and I by
the by the accounts he would just sit
there all day like in his office and
just think like in the [ __ ] matrix
bro he would have thought he would call
them thought experiments that's how we
figured out like all this [ __ ] about
light and gravity and
explain nobody explained what gravity
was until he had a theory of gravity
well people never just kind of wait
loitering well no Isaac Newton had this
theory of gravity in motion but I I'm
steins the guy who figured out the time
and spaces of fabric
oh and that gravity bends it like he
just was this guy was so brilliant he
sat in his office and he was having a
thought experiment and he imagined the
more mass you had the more you bended
this fabric of space and it's [ __ ]
crazy that's crazy imagine didn't go
into telling somebody come and tell your
neighbor that yeah bro where's Larry I
liked him better yeah I just saw a guy
outside of the DSW shoes and he yeah
crazy imagine what he you think he
[ __ ] like awesomely or you think I was
like he [ __ ] nasty it one's really
nasty science not that there's not
attractive science girls no but I don't
think he was like you know like a basic
kind of sexual guy you think he was like
doing wild stuff in equations he was
like let me yeah why don't we just drop
me from a hundred feet in China you know
if you want to do that I wish I knew it
could go either way
I bet there's drawings I bet somebody
grew him [ __ ] he's proud I imagine
some yeah oh my god wait mm-hmm
did I totally forgot uh we're supposed
to take a break I've been having such a
blast know what dance said um you having
a blast almost cried one time did you I
mean it was good but yeah it's still fun
what time at what point did you almost
fell I mean I don't know man probably
about the just I don't know man your dad
just doing ice boys yeah and the radio
did he do radio I he was she did yeah he
take by the way all my success he takes
credit
how'd you percent credit for he's like
yep that's my boy I was like that I've
done good just watch The Bachelor damn
what did you send me I can't find the
link looked it up and he had
mistresses while married because when
you're that smart and you're that
stressed you got a [ __ ] DJ I guess it's
all part of the same equation yeah if I
was real stressed out and I had to do
science all day
dirty became all items oh this [ __ ]
chromium on my sleeve [ __ ] somebody yeah
dude imagine you [ __ ] some girl and next
thing you know you left a bunch you know
like who you know you had someone your
code and you know next thing you know
she's got a theory I'm all over imagine
the lawsuit I bet he was in a lot of
lawsuits I think back then was just
different
like you could walk around women's shoes
I didn't think aids was around them like
he probably was strapping on I bet he
had aids in the house he invented it
he's like all right guys we're like I
saw into the future you don't want it
you're saying yeah hey take a whiff of
this Tiffany I love I love learning
about Einstein man he's such a [ __ ]
freak he's he's so smart he's so ahead
at a time like not only did he figure
out what the space and time are I'll
fabric mm-hmm the gravity bends he also
figured out a equals MC square which is
what he figured out what light is nobody
understood what light was what they
think it was just a bunch of brightness
around him well think well think what is
it you know it's hard to conceptualize
it yeah they probably thought it was God
well he figured out like you know
religious then it did he was so
brilliant man I'd [ __ ] him I take the
night on him you would oh yeah I think I
missed on him deposit it house Hermione
Granger not an element the Granger
Hermione Granger she might be
oh yeah that's Drive injected in a while
yeah I haven't either but yeah man and
what I have sex with Einstein dude if I
wasn't gay
wait I don't know if I would I mean I'm
not gay but if I wasn't also gay like in
another time I get back in time it
wasn't gay there yeah yeah because you
can go back in time and be gay that's
one of the things I heard you go back in
time
do you know you meet a lot of men it
depends on where you go dude
your fantasies about going back in time
but do if you use the thing think you go
back in time you get there you're like
hey I'm from the future
yeah and you're just a dude is walking
around most straight dude you like get
the [ __ ] out of my yard buddy you know
but Gators you like hey come tell me
about it you've thought about this man
well think about that though no make
sense if you're you know you show up
you're clean you know yeah a lot of
Gators I'm like oh I'll listen to this
guy [ __ ] all right you know gay guys
aren't always super friendly you know
sometimes they have sexual deviant you
know they can be really wild yeah and so
sometimes they want to do dirty stuff
and be wild with people and they so if
yeah if you were some guy who's got a
secret yeah oh that's a [ __ ] bow dude
that's [ __ ] gay babe David love uh
see yeah you're right do you wanna [ __ ]
a guy tell him you got a secret dude and
two cups of coffee back at your place
but you're I do sometimes I'm jealous of
gay dudes because they they [ __ ] so good
by gay dudes because you think like guys
are they try to [ __ ] anything already
yeah but then when you put like when you
mix that together
it's like those two elements are not
supposed to mix together like [ __ ] water
and sodium explodes yeah - gate and two
guys because they always want to [ __ ]
you put them on Grindr or whatever and
you know what they're why they call
Grindr because those dicks spark and
make [ __ ] fire but really I'm all the
grinding together Flint and Stanley huh
and I and I don't mean to uh no son see
I'm not disparaging the gay community no
I'm saying I'm jealous that they all
[ __ ] like crazy and they're working out
and they are look good yeah dude when I
was yellowy bad I would be a bad guy you
would be a good guy I wouldn't like it
though what after all that I wouldn't
like it and I think it looks fun the
parties look fun you know some of the
cocaine you know people pretending
they're not gay but really are gay looks
fun
I don't know that's not you I just
couldn't do it I got too much [ __ ] to
deal with man I think for me yeah you
know it's already I just couldn't yeah I
thought about it for a little while when
I was younger and I was like maybe I'm
gay but I was just really lonely
yeah and uh and then I was like yeah I'm
not gay man I just maybe when I'm 80
because that 80 is who gives up nobody
even cares like like who cares if that
guy want to shoot up yeah
heroin go all out some dick yeah I'm
serious I've thought about like if I'm
80 and like you passed away like if you
passed away ELA before me and I'm
sitting then and like our kids Theodore
put me in a [ __ ] old home he took our
money we work our asses off
we [ __ ] good made good investments
got a nice little fun he's gonna take
all that he's gonna get me a nice
retirement home so he doesn't feel bad
about who's gonna feel guilty so it's
like the bat Swan but they still serve
jello and [ __ ] microwave chicken I'm
like what does it matter
oh I'm gonna get some heroin I'm sayin
or all you could put me in this [ __ ]
and me give me a couple little grim you
gotta get me some air when and you gotta
fund me up you got to get me gay
prostitutes Wow
you're gonna get busted what are they
gonna do huh and at least know that
you're doing it oh I'm 80 well yeah I
agree about me by that but they're gonna
bail is dead and gone that's that's the
sorrow though if eel is gone then the
store need excite I need to bury the
sorrow after his wife passed this
happens you're basically the show Ricky
Gervais is just posted oh you're right
they're like oh yeah I have the podcast
I go when I get in a case you know dark
holes where people are we but I've never
done the time travel and that's why and
a lot of men would hit on you but it's
true man if some guys out on the
interstate right now he's from the
future right first of all if you're from
the future do you end up [ __ ]
homeless nobody's like oh hey here's
somebody from the future let me listen
no one yeah you gotta play that close to
the best way cool dude you don't drop
any f-bombs you know what I'm saying
like yeah
right now we do got a break okay we do
have to take a break guys we're gonna
take a quick break we've got so many
goofs and gasps and laughs and future
speculation to come we've got dad talk
we've got all kinds of stuff you don't
want to miss so let me just wrap up this
me introducing the commercial break so
we can get past that and get back to the
show oh you thought without further ado
you're in the commercials dude the
future stitch fix is a beautiful thing
for a guy like me and a guy like you
that wants to look good but doesn't want
to go through the hassle of going to a
store picking out clothes happy to care
about clothes maybe you don't have a mom
or a girlfriend that's sad if you don't
have a mom but maybe you don't have a
mom that picks out clothes for you like
when you were 12 years old okay that's
what stitch fix does it's an online
personal styling service that finds and
delivers clothes shoes and accessories
that fit your body budget and lifestyle
all you do all you do is go to stitch
fix comp /ht are you telling me your
size what styles you like how much you
want to spend you'll be paired with your
very own personal stylist aka
your own ela this is gonna make you look
a bomb who will hand pick items to send
them right to your door you try them on
eBay only for what you love and you
return the rest shipping and exchanges
and returns are always free there's no
subscription required you can sign up to
receive scheduled shipments or get your
fixed whenever you want their styling
fee is only 20 bucks which is applied
towards anything you keep from your
shipment so if you want to look bomb if
you want to look sharp and you don't
want to waste your time at Macy's
nightmare that places then get on over
right now Citrix comm / h3 you get an
extra 25% off when you keep all the
items in your box that's stitch fix comm
/ H free to get started a sit fix comm /
h3 guys honey is free money it's that
simple and it's that true it's a free
browser extension that when you shop
when you checkout at online stores it
searches the web and automatically
applies them for the bomb as coupons
what's the catch there isn't one you
can't catch this because it's way too
fast does that analogy work yes
ela says honey it's free it takes two
clicks
here for example Lila was doing some
shopping just the other day for some
outdoor furniture boom what do you know
we were about to pay full price 132
bucks
honey steps in and says sorry buster
sorry to close it overstock X or
whatever was the way name of the website
over it's not over stock there's no way
the and they're like oh we're gonna get
132 honey's like hold on not so fast
you're getting 112 because they applied
a coupon
boom automatically and saved us $20
without even thinking about it it is
literally free money it's so easy to
install put it try it for a week try it
yourself there's nothing to lose if you
know lucky you're in the stall for Frick
so you're not obligated hundred thousand
five star reviews on Google Chrome store
okay it saves ten million members an
average of twenty eight dollars 61 cents
there's no reason it's free to use easy
install just two clicks so go shop with
confidence get honey for free at join
honeycomb /hz that's join honey a.com
slash h3 the smart shopping assistant
that saves you time and money when
you're shopping online apologies to all
you bald sons of [ __ ] out there but
you need to hear what I'm about to tell
you okay first of all it's not your
fault because 66 percent of men start to
lose their hair by their age by the time
they're age 35 and once you've noticed
it started thinning it's already too
late so here's what we need to do we
need to attack this now what you still
had a shot at a happy normal life it's
not that dramatic but I usually
recommend guys listen to this
for Hamm's calm it's a one stop shop for
a hair loss skin care sexual wellness
for men thanks to science baldness can
be optional we've got to prevent prevent
prevent guys you don't want to be in
that situation in the shower and your
hair is going down the drain like that
scene from psycho okay
prevent prevent prevent science is here
to help we are helping guys to be the
best version themselves with licensed
physicians and fda-approved products to
help treat hair loss this is the real
deal these are prescriptions backed by
science his group was created by a guy
who knows
some men's health conversations are
easier online than in-person this you
don't have to have an awkward in-person
doctor visit or long Pharmacy line for
hims connects you to real doctors online
which can save you hours completely
confidential and discreet well there's
nothing discreet about going bald it's
pretty obvious that's so ya get their
loss treatment everyone is talking about
featured in GQ Men's Health Esquire and
playboy just to name a few
this is the real effing deal my
listeners can get started for hims
complete hair loss kit for just five
dollars right now today while supplies
last and of course subject to the
doctor's approval because this is the
real deal restrictions apply and you're
going to need to see the website for
full details but this would cost you
hundreds of dollars if you went to the
doctor or pharmacy or anywhere else so
right now let's cure that bald [ __ ]
editor's and get some beautiful hair
back on that thing and I'm not talking
about duct tape and pubes I'm talking
about real hair the curls out of your
head go to for hems calm /h Street
that's fo r hims calm /h three four
hands calm /h three shopping for
insurance is a nightmare because you go
directly to the big boys and they rip
you off but when you have a website like
policy genius that automatically
compares to the prices and the quality
of the plans you're gonna find yourself
having a much easier time and a way
better price that's the beauty of policy
genius in two minutes you can compare
quotes from top insurance to find the
best policy for you I'm talking car
insurance I'm talking renter's insurance
I'm talking disability insurance I'm
talking life insurance if you have
anything your life worth leaving
anything to kind of dark but funny when
you pull in line the advisors at policy
genius will handle all the red tape they
leave a negotiate your rate with the
insurance company no Commission sales
agents no hidden fees just helpful
advice and personalized service I
personally hate dealing with directly
with these insurance companies you need
someone in between makes such a big
difference
Paul each policy genius it's in the name
they're geniuses okay so if you find the
whole thing puzzling head on over to
policy genius doc
komm because in two minutes you can
compare quotes find the right policy and
save up to 40% billing it and that's
actually serious
I've personally saved a ton of money
through going through brokers instead of
going straight so policy genius okay
guys hit it up it's the easy we're way
to compare and buy insurance policies
policy genius.com
back with Theo von we were talking about
well first of all guys okay have you
been convinced yet that that you need to
catch him on tour go to Theo von Romme
and get some tickets right right safe
yeah good all right next we're doing
some shows out it'd be fun yeah weekend
if you like the heat you like the you
know what else do they have I think they
got illegal immigrants if you like that
I mean that's a place to meet them yeah
you know they're looking to meet people
I'm sure house they're not a dating site
for the head there you just got here
because ice would be like I should make
that site oh that's true legal illegal
date dot ice yeah paperless gov gov
that's so weird paperless looking to
meet somebody because that there
probably is a real need for that
actually when you think about it whether
they all hang out around the same spots
they met each other they're back they
they're there they're doing it the
old-fashioned way they meet up at the
[ __ ] I don't wanna say anything to
slippery slope Ross Dress for Less
that's what I'm thinking to my boss
they yeah you were wrong yeah no I like
Ross but hyotei is in the sale bin
coming it's the dog they got some
undercurrents you know what else is
crazy what's that one across a buyer I
don't want to see I can't say it cuz I
gotta find out how it's done I was
enjoying that conversation yeah what did
you want to go in a different direction
well just to remember that remember that
song riders on the stone yeah of course
you know that song was about advertisers
people that advertise they got plane
that that that part of it was about you
know when they have a plane in the air
eat they said like eat at Joe's a big
item okay I saw that in a documentary on
hate radio and I was like what deaf [ __ ]
that that's what that line was a browser
because I was thinking like like you
your imagination goes wild when you hear
these lines yeah Dan that's so sick but
he was just tripping out in the desert
and there was a [ __ ] airplane with
the scientists baffling man and I was
like that's not that psychedelic yeah
it's like hey if it was just like did I
mean he he made it sound really cool
yeah but yeah riders on the storm LLC
I'm sure it says yeah yeah defunct now
yeah yeah yeah that's just one of those
cases of the world is not always as it
seems now
yeah cuz I think riders on the storm
what is it like you know I still picture
like a dark guy and like a boat with
like lightning coming out of his eyes
yeah you know just like in a rowboat on
a cloud kind of close there's a guy in a
plane maybe with some but no goggles on
yeah probably drinking tang they stepped
tang backbone tank spike tank what do
you spike ting with I think probably
liquor more water if it's too thick
later
I don't think water spiking that's a
hard life when you spike with water I'm
gonna spike this punch it's way too
sweet I got to dilute this good I was
you got me thinking about Einstein
though you got me thinking about it I
don't even know what I mean I barely I
knew a little bit about it what he did
I've seen his black on my photos mm-hmm
you know I've seen some of the drawings
of each he he probably changed the world
this is a hard statement to quantify but
he probably changed the world more than
any certainly that's so hard to quantify
who could say yeah be out of him in
Jesus Christ probably he's just crisis
watch and then the white when you watch
The Bachelor if you leave today we're
all watch The Bachelor right I'll watch
it at home or watch it on Hulu like the
delayed episode wait who's Daniel white
Dana White who does the UFC that guy is
oh he brought back kind of like Roman
fighting okay you know trying to think
of other people that are black theater
ask [ __ ] yeah are you not entertained
yeah yeah that's kind of but I'm trying
to think of other people that have
really changed the world sorry I was
just
yeah I thought you my mind I was like we
owe this guy saw him forever no yeah
we've been talking a lot I'm Stein
watched The Bachelor is what you owe
well that's a question would he get
addicted to the thing would it ended his
whole career yeah he didn't have like my
dad he's like oh yeah he would have take
it but if my dad was like the [ __ ]
smartest guy everybody just watched The
Bachelor all day you watch this [ __ ]
even worse than that bro yeah does he -
what's worth what else
actually there's just well so where's
darker place yet because that's a real
addicted the bachelors addictive this
flowers there's love this possibility
there's traveling I always wonder why
I'm watching it - oh yeah while I'm
watching it it's simultaneously but
there so there is worse than The
Bachelor but at a certain point it
becomes kind of dope like when you go on
TLC and you see shows like my little
life yeah my huge wife my littlest life
yes about little people it's like white
that's it yeah
it's about a family of little people
because it's so free because it's all so
you can't even really unless you're a
neighbor you can't go hang out with a
family of little people that is a luxury
that may be reason I have yeah if you
even from two houses over you can't [ __ ]
him to stop by a mill around all the
time taking photos and that would be
strange so a lot of it is the ability to
just drop in there and see what's going
on yeah you know a little bit little
people big problems was one day oh wow
they actually named it that well cuz if
they're originally they had a little
people big world with the pumpkin
farmers fascinating yeah and then they
had you know you growing the largest
vegetables and you're smaller yes how do
you even carry that pumpkin and how do
you even just to take that on and say
you know what yeah we could grow
kumquats brah we could grow grapes like
our other [ __ ] you know like our
ancestors as little weak [ __ ] but
let's go [ __ ] large bro let's go
pumpkins and change the world and they
did you know the Roloffs man I followed
that family you know I think the son was
a male model for a little while in
college you know followed them up until
I about four years ago what happened I
got tired of it and also then I realized
they're children I'm looking up children
on the Internet oh yeah even though I
was doing a perm
you know just kind reasons I felt like
it was still started to make me it was
wind also a lot of
we're doing it for uncon reasons that
I'm gonna get caught up because I was
using my neighbor's Wi-Fi he's a good
guy and I don't want that I people
handed on him there every time somebody
knocked on his door kit here I'm gonna
text it right now it just say look scary
that you can use someone's wife fine
through all this gnarly [ __ ] like I know
that never even occurred to me at all
somewhat recently i remember i when i
was broke in college i asked my neighbor
can't believe I did that you there's two
there's two types of people in this
world people who ask if they can use
their neighbor's Wi-Fi and those the
doll yeah I need a cup of your Wi-Fi and
you did it well I was like bro we just
split the car oh that's a good deal okay
because I was broke and the internet was
[ __ ] expensive and they were
predatory too and that college town
they're like oh yeah you need a little
internet $60 a month to him I'm like bro
I didn't even
yeah I'm net I'm losing money every day
you know so I said I'll give you 30
bucks let's split the internet and I
just downloaded a ton of kiddie porn and
I think jail now Jesus Christ no that's
all that's joking oh yeah
dude I remember when the before they
even had child pornography when children
were just not you know doing that and
they had somebody one time when I was in
college sent me a picture of two old men
and they were naked in a room I remember
getting this email out lemonparty and
they'd seen the same image and they had
a kid like sitting on a bed no I haven't
seen that image right and I in my mind
I'd never thought about old people and
children and sex you know or anything
wild like that so I remember seeing me
like oh this is [ __ ] hilarious but I
remember seeing him in like what a crazy
idea like you know everybody is naked
you know and so like life is naked this
is just an you know it's almost like an
art like this is how people you know
it's like this is when they're old and
this is when they're young and these
guys are you know watching TV or
whatever you know I thought so I sent it
to everybody I knew I was like god this
is so silly and dude I remember like two
years later running into an
ex-girlfriend and she goes well what
have you been up to with your life right
she was yeah well nobody will forget
that time you send that picture of two
pin and then make it kid everybody know
like that's what that was
oh my guess what that was if you look at
it like a freak executed by everybody
you know I just thought it was like I
thought it was like seeing a couple
rabbits in a yard you know when you see
two rabbits on a goats back like in a
photo sure yeah like I thought it was
like that oh let's just mix the world
you know I didn't think of it as sad did
you get any responses I know that girls
won seven when that girl told me that
then I started to feel I mean I think
that probably made me feel bad about
myself because then I thought I don't
remember I don't have that account
anymore you know who's on that email
list seen that it's still looking for
you she also said the kid she goes was
that you in the photo because the kid
looked like me a little bit that's why I
think somebody had originally sent it to
me like hey man is this you I was like
no it's not me dude I don't know two old
people that would be naked in a room
with me you know and just take him
photos so I wasn't thinking like oh
these guys are being dirty you know it's
sad that you can't even be safe you
can't be even clean anymore sometimes if
you want to of heart without it going to
like a dirty place you look at a tribe
you see now those photos those people
standing around a fire all the time
everybody's [ __ ] naked yeah but
that's okay no I agree it's you know you
know to you know through to seniors and
uh you know and a seven-year-old in a
motel 6 and suddenly now that's everyone
you know yeah it's not cool that's not
cool my yeah bro you know that ain't I
err so it's different it's a bit
different how we see it through
different lenses and it's unfair
sometimes yeah like if you took a
picture in your yard you got your
grandparents to be outside naked right
and they're nice people
mm-hm and then you get your little
nephews to be out there right and you
get a cute picture of them out by the
clothing line mm-hmm and they're all
naked but it's nice outside right it's
not nighttime and then you send that to
a call people like wow crazy day looking
for food right okay but you take a
picture out of any National Geographic
which is basically what they're saying
if every single one
and suddenly those people totally fine
doing anything Wow it's just people
looking for goji berries and then you
over here just because it takes place a
you know a couple miles Detroit
everybody's going to jail it's crazy
it's crazy you can't be a clean family
you can't be a family that just you know
everything it's now and I don't know if
the perversion comes from the inside
these days as much as it comes from the
outside you know absolutely yeah because
while all the sudden everybody's a
pedophile
ya know what happened yeah why's
everybody [ __ ] just bored out walking
the most people just looking at him
making them well sure I mean yeah that's
the locals are say that you're right I
should have said that yeah well it's
important to get the facts made yeah
yeah we don't want people thinking about
that or I don't anyway and I said but
it's your show what do I mean know by
air but like why you know I think about
that myself like why all of a sudden it
seems like that's like the cool thing to
do not like cool but like all these
powerful old folks are just like putting
their do what's going on yeah yeah if
they just got now some of it could be an
extreme wealth you know it back in Rome
whenever they got too much power at a
certain point they just ran out of
things to do and so like you know your
lizard mind goes to that next thing you
got that sugar lizard your head like I
never tried tennis is always happening
but you don't have their I guess you
couldn't have the exposure I just I I
try to you have to be so evil to do that
I was talking about the Michael Jackson
thing a lot I don't know if you want to
get it so polarizing and you don't want
if you don't have a strong opinion
I wouldn't even recommend yeah I don't
have any opinion come to your house you
get it wrong I mean I'll but but but
people like let's say hypothetically he
did it mmm-hmm it's like yeah you just
like why you gonna [ __ ] kids but did he
start what do you think here's the thing
and here's our thing it's a good point
there's good-looking people out there
why do you have to he probably
I would guess stop developing
emotionally at some young age but you
still develop sexually so then you have
these weird young emotions that are very
real like oh you know like giving a
Valentine to a kid you know to a kid at
school or you know like your first
girlfriend or like kissing behind a tree
you have all those like little things
that are real to you as an adult as you
stopped emotionally there but sexually
you're still you know your your whatever
age you are so I would guess when those
two things meld in the weird world he
was in of ego and also then a capability
and then you end up probably doing in
that type of a weird world so they feel
okay that's that's a good insight you
gotta be right about that
maybe I am no well there's got to be a
reason but the thing is like you can be
attracted to kids but you don't have to
molest them yeah that takes a special
evil because it's like if you're
attracted to kids I don't know what
happened in your life to make you that
way but it's out of your control I don't
think anyone would would uh would choose
to be attracted to kids
oh no I mean that's a horrible that's
all curse yeah imagine bending down
every time you want it you know hug
somebody or kissing you know or you
having to get down you know like sit
down and that would be horrible you
couldn't date a kid yeah you couldn't
they can't you can't go to any of the
same places people would look at you
weird yeah you know you'd have to put
mustaches on man that would be crazy to
really date them you know I'm not the
kind of guy who would have sex with the
child ever you know would I take a kid
out for a nice meal and drop them off
without touching them yeah that's good
on you I am that guy that's good yeah
bro you want true why does it become
such a thing now that every person cuz
then it makes it oh you don't want to
interact with kids and then the kids
everybody's scary person because they're
not interacting with everyone scared
everyone's a pedophile everyone's a
predator it feels like real scary and
then it makes you super paranoid about
yourself too like yeah like I don't know
you know what I mean yeah you know yeah
oh dude I don't know when we were young
we used to go to the armed kmb store
they used to have a kmb store it was
like a CVS before
CVS and Walgreens bought everybody out
and we'd be in the store do me and my
friend Daniel and you had to run over if
he said when they had a kid we'd be like
dude you sneak over there touch that
kids neck and run off right so we would
just play this game like how many next
kids next you could walk like nothing
crazy sexual touch that kids neck and
escape will do this bro we get up to
about 30 kids necks in a day bro people
[ __ ] like scared
[Laughter]
we got a little too freakin wild and I
remember this one boy's dad beat the
[ __ ] out of him was that Werther's
Originals he beat him with a bag of
Werther's robinette [ __ ] hurt him how
bad is it wasn't that big of a bag mean
the only head like right there hard and
when you get him mixed up that densely
yeah it's a packs of extra punch yeah
and he'd beaten with a couple bags
actually I love those there's two types
people in the world people who love were
theirs and people that don't you look
where there's I do I love them I didn't
think I would though I think it's okay
you used to hate him
yeah what's changed since you are with
child that you now or uh do you feel
like food was there anything taste wiser
mmm just eating a lot of sweets yeah
sugar baby
it's a thing they called sympathy
Michael you should have seen this burger
yesterday I wish we took a picture of it
man I don't want to make a dude I've
gained like 20 pounds Wow
because she's not much of an eater and
when she eats I get excited yeah cuz I'm
repressing my hunger all the time around
her right and now she's eating so now
you get to let it and the monsters out
yeah he's raging my little Einstein and
he don't love lettuce you know I'll take
I'll eat lettuce as long as I'm three
[ __ ] patty row three patty lettuce is
one of the best things ever
bro you watch the but I saw you tweet
about the Bachelorette you watch The
Bachelor dude I went over to David
Spade's house one item watch the
bathroom which was very crazy was he's
super into it he loves it like too much
way too much he knew everyone and not
only that he made me sit on the sofa he
sat behind the sofa in a chair you don't
like sofas do but that's that Broman
thing you get so Roman that you get
furniture
you don't sleep on a bag you sleep in a
[ __ ] you know you got four men
holding you up it's not more comfortable
it's just higher level yes what can I do
next yeah so but yeah we watched a full
episode and you know I've enjoyed it
okay because I saw you tweeting out
about the Bachelorette choice of Hanabi
you said no yes you're familiar enough
with her is that such it I found her to
be the least likable one on the whole
show yes and they gave her I think about
the whole premise of The Bachelor that
trips me out is the assumption that
everybody wants to marry this person
it's like it's like that person's not
like the new one with Colton I was like
this [ __ ] doesn't have a job
yeah yeah they go they kept going yeah I
guess he's like a big strong guy so the
girls kept being like he makes me feel
safe as a you know to make a girl feel
safe get a [ __ ] job
yeah go war and a lot but yeah it's like
yeah what's he gonna like what they
gotta have a job it's like what do they
find it what are they competing for this
guy he he's never even [ __ ] he's a
virgin yeah yeah he hasn't [ __ ] and he
doesn't have a job this guy's not even a
catch dude he's basically and he's like
a middle school that's everybody in
middle school boy or girl and they
vanish like hold hands and kiss and
they're like I want to marry him yeah
and I'm supposed to believe that they're
all about and so I guess that's part of
the joys because it's so
but then when I really got a dose of
reality is the episodes when they said
with the live audience oh yeah and
they're 90 percent women and they're
like they're so into it that's the what
these women fantasize the fans about a
man who can keep them safe doesn't have
a job and has never had sex yeah they
were so invested I like three guys yeah
I didn't I can do that I think I don't
even like doing sex that much man it's
really you know it's like me I feel like
it's like meeting somebody during like a
busy time of day and having to be
exactly on time just makes me kind of
what you've said and I stand it because
as Jerry Seinfeld once said and I love
forgot for many guys sex is just like a
car crash yes is just lots of noise
confusion screeching yeah and then you
guys are staying on another onion you're
in just two people that have just [ __ ]
that are in a room together right what
now
yeah what's the maxillary yeah well
that's what Sibylla are all times I
should all didn't analyze a 24-hour bath
routine oh yeah that's a good call did
you see actually I want to show you some
videos oh yeah
did you see the guy rapping for Hanabi
did you know how they Brett they bring
out these guys you can watch it right
here
now Colton's handsome I mean he's
handsome he is he might not like him
because he's handsome at all you have a
thing no I do not
yeah in fact I would say I you know when
I was younger I used to resent handsome
guys yeah but as I've matured and as I
found my own I mean I've listened it
would be violating I don't need anything
I'm good I don't resent handsome guys so
I look at him I say that's a handsome
guy mmm-hmm he's probably his dick is
probably so small that's why he's never
[ __ ] you think his dick is probably
like a size of a tic tac why would that
kind off ever [ __ ] why would he why see
why would that it doesn't make sense
maybe there's a fish you know sheepish
cuz his dicks the size of a little
[ __ ] baby ACORN not even like a fully
won't grown ACORN I don't know why you
think man that's what I that's what I it
see
like well yeah may I don't know I don't
dislike him but it's just a guy he's
just a [ __ ] guy right I see he's just
a guy on the street that I passed by and
now all the whoa what about one of these
girls what do they know about him other
than he's attractive right yeah I guess
I am angry yeah because of that I can
grease and I'm angry at a lot of things
and I don't know I'm angry right I get
that man I get angry a lot of times dude
like I find myself [ __ ] angry bro and
I'm just like what am I so angry and
yeah hey people like what can I do for
you
[ __ ] I'm still angry shut up yeah yeah I
get mad at I get mad at everything
wonder what that comes from man that
makes me mad too cuz I I'm so funny you
say that I'm gonna fight in my life
right now it's just like I'm angry about
stuff sometimes and everything is going
ok that's the one then that makes it
worse and why do I deal with it with
anger yeah what I eat with anger yeah
you get mad at yourself you get angry at
yourself the real truth is that I
believe it's self-loathing like so no
matter what is going on you the source
of anger isn't is yourself so you can't
escape it mmm like if you react the way
you react it's all comes down to how you
feel about things and if you're the way
you're reacting to things is frustrating
you're you're not enjoying the way
you're acting you're acting unhealthy
like I always get angry or irritable yes
so you you hate yourself and you get
tired of it this is dark it's kind of
dark but you get tired of being yourself
in a lot of ways yeah and so I feel like
it's an anger that's always there at
yourself so it kind of bubbles out right
yeah but there I don't know they're you
know no I think if that's true there's
an anger somewhere inside of me always
at myself for some reasons that are
probably even invisible or might at some
point in my life I thought I you know I
thought bad things about myself thought
negative things I experience things that
something was wrong with me so then I
got angry at the way that I was mm-hmm
so yeah maybe there's a bunch of anger
there
but then like how do I beat it you know
so probably you know probably helping
other people somehow I think that's a
beautiful thought I mean I haven't
developed that far yet I'm still selfish
yeah I mean I'm just trying to think how
to beat it because it can't stay inside
you for them right no that's a really
that's really wise I've just started
like therapy and taking antidepressants
oh wow you're just there you just got I
started that like six months ago Wow and
before that I was a [ __ ] mess bro
like I was could not function Wow like I
literally couldn't function so that's
been a painful man people think then
you're mean to sometimes not saying you
and I never was ever heard that I'm
saying that I don't know I was mean but
that's the thing and then you can't
function it's miserable being miserable
and the worse it smell and like you said
you've got everything going for you got
the dream job you're married wife you
got that not zygote all going on wavy on
zag or trimester super wizard yeah yeah
man a lot of blessings huh and then and
then you're like [ __ ] you know it's
funny you know did I just I keep talking
about it because I'm dealing with some
of the same stuff like everything's okay
and then why can't I just you found
yourself you're angry a lot recently
yeah and just I don't know what it's at
and I I don't let it out very much you
know but it's like yeah I just don't
know why I'm just so frustrated you know
you get em when you don't let it out
then it comes out in a different way
you're not even aware right like I don't
know I noticed how about me what about
me
I was another how you tolerated me not
necessarily you I had this weird like
shoulder pain oh dude it's it's it's
gonna sound crazy but I had this
shoulder pain that started out of
nowhere and then it just kept getting
worse and worse and worse until like
when I would get it it would last for
like a week and I couldn't function and
like I did all the tests and MRI
whatever and everything was fine sorry
you sip of water yeah take your time I
get nervous sometimes and when there's
dead air but really there's nothing
wrong you know what that wasn't that bad
of a dead air moment sometimes I'll be
listening to shows and the dead air goes
for so long you gotta like open your
phone and you bet it's still playing
yeah oh there's one more a guy died
there's an early dinner and people are
like oh [ __ ] man and people the funny
thing is you'll be listen if you don't
know we died you're like what the [ __ ]
man you're [ __ ] with me again [ __ ]
with notes first piece of [ __ ] this so
much that's a [ __ ] suave move if
you're gonna die okay go in there buddy
yeah no I let's go back to a live air
yeah I ended up you actually bought me
this book about the pain treatment was
heard of Howard Stern I'm a fan of
Howard Stern hmm and he was and this I
this sounded like pseudoscience the
stupidest [ __ ] ever but he is always
going on and on about this doctor he's a
genius he saved my life
he's lightyears ahead and and I was like
well okay I'm gonna buy this book for
ela because there's people out there
with back pain they probably want to
know that I yeah man I've partial
discectomy what is that it took out part
of my desk Oh at the hospital were you
injured yeah
so I'll find it in a second but I I
started reading this book and like it
sounded like complete [ __ ] at first
and I almost I almost like just gave up
on the book but I kept reading and at
first he's just describing your symptoms
and it was like spot-on exactly what I
was experiencing and then he describes
the calm personality that usually
happens to him and it was exactly me too
and then he starts explaining that
basically it's it's actually
psychological and it comes from
something that caused a bunch of anger
and you knew that you weren't aware of
and your body you weren't letting it out
so it ends up manifesting itself in this
way that makes the pain and it was like
it's gonna sound crazy but the treatment
is just understanding that that's what
it is and then it actually goes away and
it went away
and like I couldn't believe it I kept
telling either dude like it's so
ridiculous because I don't believe [ __ ]
I'm the most cynical [ __ ]
you thought that why don't ya notice she
wouldn't she wouldn't even wear
necklaces I stopped wearing jackets even
like anything a little heavy it was a
real sensitivity yeah hmm and I so she
read this [ __ ] I didn't think you
finished the book you just read half of
it what you were healed I well the
banding was just kind of who reads a
whole book I got no but like that that
was a real shocking thing to me because
I truly never believed in life in that
kind of like mystical connection she's
like mine and body like that literal
healing back pain I think that's what it
is I think it's what was called yeah and
the guy he don't [ __ ] her up the title
it's just called healing back pain Jesus
yeah yeah man XII pain I think a lot of
it does come from stress and hiding it
in different places and stuff like that
my mother goes to a tapping place they
do a tapping like the people that tap
you and
they just sloppy around yeah basically
really yeah I mean you got to pay them
you know dude I used to go downtown when
I first moved here a couple Vietnamese
dudes would beat the [ __ ] out of here
for 40 50 $70 and they put you in that
dog suit the bite suit that they have
you know at FBI training and next thing
you know dude these guys are beat the
[ __ ] out of you and brought what you
left there you you didn't have a lot to
worry about
Oh give me I'll get that recommendation
from you yeah I don't still open I can't
X it's dealing back then no it's okay
when you get angry do you get angry like
inanimate objects or people like how do
you show your anger
you're fresh or you're so it's a good
question man um I think I get angry at
inanimate objects mm-hmm I lose my
ability to to have empathy or sympathy
you know in brief moments and a lot of
times for me it's about control anything
where there's like control like I don't
want somebody controlling me I don't
like somebody telling me what to do
mm-hm which makes it sometimes tough for
me to work with others but I'm
recognizing that those are two different
things now so I can start to have a
little bit more peace about them but
yeah and so when I feel like somebody's
trying to tell me what to do or there's
control or somebody didn't treat or it's
not somebody's they're not being fair to
me or to someone else like those are the
things that really like fairness I feel
like it's very you know that makes me
just so angry I feel like but yeah when
I meant when I get angry it just yeah it
sometimes it's just like this gremlin
inside of me that just wants to [ __ ]
escape you know and I don't know and
sometimes I'll just yeah be rude I'll be
short with people sometimes and usually
it's people that I work with so it's
like more in a work environment
fortunately I feel like I'm able to come
back around and like recognize it a lot
of times but I still wish that I could
eradicate it you know the worst is I
used to did I totally feel the same way
I don't think I really had I don't
understand my triggers but I would get
in these really pissy and I would come
in here to the office and let me short
and just [ __ ] such a [ __ ] you know
yeah and I didn't and I so didn't want
to be that way and I'd be like even in
my own head like oh it's one of those
days where I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
where I'm an [ __ ] yeah cuz then
you're really at a certain point I'm
being victim I am being a weak to
whatever is controlling me and so that
started to be like that have just
recently started to be like even in this
conversation I need to find some healthy
means to be able to figure that out and
process it so that I don't let this
anger have control over me because it
shouldn't you know because then it just
yeah it just affects other people and
and you don't want to be meeting other
people you don't want to hurt anybody
especially people that always like being
supportive or trying to help
exactly and you don't worry yeah you
can't work you can't appreciate people
you become you become so cynical right
and then like like [ __ ] like that guys
didn't he [ __ ] up and didn't do this
and he didn't do that yeah cuz you your
lens you got that dark lens on yeah yeah
that's exactly yeah it's a perspective
thing it's it it's true and then when
you put on those [ __ ] clear glasses
that is reality yes like oh this guy's
tried his best guys the best and like I
do everything perfect [ __ ] no oh yeah
and and then I'm the guy who shows up at
the last minute it was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
doesn't do [ __ ] comes here leaves them
work and they're the [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
you
I know [ __ ] that guy [ __ ] that and I
would hate that guy
yeah yeah that's the that's the that's I
think the deep truth is that knowing you
would hate that guy
if you met him yeah you'd be like [ __ ]
that guy's a [ __ ] douche yeah why
would he be like that yeah yeah it's sad
and that's what I would also think from
about that guy oh that's sad man and it
said that he feels that way I said that
he has so much anger about something it
said that he can't see the joys in his
own life you know
yeah it's uh I don't know I think this
conversation is even kind of helpful to
think about it doesn't happen to me a
lot but I do notice it happens to me and
some of it is like how much stress do I
want to put on myself am I trying to do
too much am i reaching outside of my
means so that my system is trying to
tell me hey man like this isn't some of
your path you're being tempted by you
know different things or things you
don't even want to be and right that's
truth there's truth to that I found that
to be true it's hard to recognize those
signals - it takes wisdom yeah I think
it's it's hard to recognize him it takes
even having conversations like this I
think yeah you know in my love I love I
think a lot of people I think everybody
to one degree or another can relate oh
yeah I don't have to be in any position
and so I think that I love having
conversations like this because on a
personal level yeah I love it I love
hearing what you're going through
yeah someone who's in a similar
situation of me but then other people
who everyone blames themselves I think
in general I know I have a problem and I
think people in general have a problem
like loving like genuinely loving
themselves or you don't have to love
yourself you just can tolerate yourself
it's almost sounds like insane to me
yeah idea of loving yourself it is maybe
it's name I don't know but like what do
you mean by that
sorry to interrupt you I because I'm so
not capable you having myself that it
almost sounds to me like a joke when you
say it's like a little psycho oh yeah oh
it's crazy yeah I actually feel the same
way like it almost well then it's like
what are you a narcissist what do you
love yourself you're not that great
right the [ __ ] do you write but yeah but
see that point and whenever that part
isn't us that thing will never stop that
thing will always hit the ball from one
side of the court and then go to the
other side with the same rack and then
you know whatever that thing is it tells
you that that thing doesn't care about
us at all that thing is like a that's
the dark arts and that's the thing it
lives in us it does not care about us at
all hmm you know it'll come it'll hit
the ball back and forth forever and
you'll just [ __ ] be this guy that
plays this game or not you or any of us
you know will be this person that plays
this game that's not even
real and we weren't even you know we
could have walked off the court and had
a blast hmm
that's the [ __ ] that's the that's a
great analogy
you're a wordsmith did you know that I
don't know about that man you got to
accept the compliment
thanks man yeah because it's the same
part of us that doesn't accept
compliments to your right right you're
right look I'm not as fast Yeah right
yeah you're right so guy that's sweet of
your wall I appreciate you know you guys
are nice timing it's a nice conversation
and it's nice that you guys at a time of
your life you know like I get scared
about like maybe you know getting in a
relationship and having a family and
that kind of stuff and it's interesting
to see that you guys are thinking about
some of these things right now when
you're about to have a baby and
definitely in there yeah by influencing
a kid you know you can really change the
way that things happen in the world and
things that happen in your in our own
lives you know and we can you know cut
off you know bad things that have gone
down our own you know tributaries of
genealogy and we can change them I think
you know with good parenting and with
with you know with thinking about these
kind of things I hope so I certainly
hope so we'll see see how badly we [ __ ]
them up it's more just like it's more
like a measure of like how bad we [ __ ]
this kid up on a one to ten it's not how
good of a parent were we
how bad of a parent we really it's crazy
we are in that bad parent now it's like
almost every parent it's like they were
a bad parent huh I think it's a
generational thing right I think we're
all kind of [ __ ] up parentless people
anyway I feel like I'm parentless them
anyways when I think about the way my
dad was treated by his parents they were
like things he slept in a barn on a oh
wow no he's not that man oh really
I was thinking well because they settled
Italy been on the sand tonight joking
but that's real
yeah those [ __ ] but Annie Annie
was like one of ten siblings
deepers and I'm sure the parents didn't
pay attention
you're right it'd be hard to yeah you're
right and it's kind of worth work
I think generationally becoming better
maybe yeah or maybe and also part of our
spirit I think is becoming weak or that
like like you know we get told we get
we're a lot more in this self-help time
you know I noticed like my mother you
know later in her life has read more
self-help books like that kind of thing
has become more of a maybe introspection
maybe our kids will be more on the way
out of that maybe where they're not
they're just living their lives and not
examining it's almost a blessing to be
able to sit here and examine what our
lives I'd like you know because
otherwise we'd be like you know and
[ __ ] fighting and lter yeah
hunting leopards yeah yeah you don't
have time real salt of the earth [ __ ] we
need some [ __ ] survival bring you to
wash yeah well that's why that's why I'm
so anxious would be watch [ __ ] batch
watch Gold Rush dude man huh i watch
gold
those guys are great yeah they're like
man I [ __ ] spent all winter in Alaska
blowing up mountains when I make 200
bucks yeah it was a good it was a good
one man versus why who hunts gold and
versus Detroit have you seen that no
destroy no it is over there did show
though just some guy just kind of
survived in Detroit a lot of probably
the most dangerous yeah of all yeah a
lot of missing Nate lineup a lot of that
[ __ ] you know a lot of people go missing
in a Detroit yeah you know it's almost
become like the thing to do like if you
seem Larry know they can escape room
high-level escape zone actually there's
a company I heard they you know they
have like yeah you know how they have
like really cool paintball obstacle
courses paintball war yeah that's a
Detroit essentially somebody opened up a
Gaza Strip paintball place here that
that's [ __ ] up if no yeah I did hear
that I know you're [ __ ] I'm trying to
think of where that's at I think here
that the yeah it's somewhere out in LA
it's somewhere out yeah and once sight
is Israeli on one side I mean I hear it
sir
real [ __ ] showdown over there that's
the fast man
and then there's really set you get
there's really site you get like fly by
paint buckets yeah just drop paint on
the on the Palestinians but it's not
it's mostly American Jewish people are
out there so it's like a lot of inhalers
a lot of people with asthma yeah yeah
but it's fine because they have the they
have got like just tubs of paint how
much time we got
we got 30 minutes I'm savoring every
minute with this yeah well we go back in
that Einstein conversation man doing a
future travel ëcoz yeah so I son is like
humanity he's a guy he's like a paradigm
shift guy like nothing was the same
after him right this one guy out of
billions and that's the numbers game
like Einstein could have easily he
almost got wiped out by the not by the
Nazis did he really yeah he escaped
World War two to America he survived
barely he almost got wiped out the
millions and millions of people that
were wiped out just imagine what could
have been lost the potential that one
person has to change the world for
everybody to get a little got little
line II yeah Wow you know and so I and
then so I think about that and then how
it says such a numbers game right like
you've got all of humanity and then like
every like a thousand years one dude
comes along who's so [ __ ] smart he's
not change everything he's like what the
[ __ ] have you guys been doing he got
cheese and bread you have no sandwiches
there was a guy that did that
his name was Sam Williams sandwich
really on Wikipedia look at oh wow
Williams sandwich I'll look that up man
yes but yeah Einstein was that guy dude
and that's why I thought maybe he could
be from the future because if you come
from the future this [ __ ] is just [ __ ]
you know you got a little pad it's like
Biff from Back to the Future very moment
but yeah how could you know that much
and to be of the same like like you know
there's there's evidence that their time
travel is you know why I've heard this
there's a paradox and it makes sense if
there was time travelers mm-hmm
wouldn't they have already come back
already you're saying there is evidence
that there is time there's not there's
not if there was humanity ever had the
chance to time travel hmm
wouldn't they have already visited like
the dude if so from the future
worthiness yeah whether they'd be here
and be like oh I'm from the future
they would always have been here right
but always necessarily know right if
they tell you their time traveler but
there's a youth yeah fake right it would
seem like hey I met this time traveler
and bring him into your office no way
everybody would be hrs you peel em I
told me that once and it made a lot of
sense to me but now it doesn't feel that
good of a point but could you really
keep that a secret
there's no slipping in and out of time
and [ __ ] in movies they gotta go back
and fix something they always gotta go
unnoticed I know but they [ __ ] it up so
bad in the movies like just imagine what
it would really be like because
reality's always stranger than fiction
right oh that's a great that's a great
point I did so I think they would
probably send a woman I think mmm a gay
woman woman could keep a secret better
than a man a lesbian yeah let's get
pretty violent those nude a lot of times
if it's a late at night after 1:00 a.m.
you know I'm 11 p.m. in under for life
great woman yeah probably a little
because a lesbian I get if you sent
somebody into a time where their
sexuality was like kind of still not not
rare I mean it's not that rare anymore
but if it were you know if they maybe
too much under a they might already you
want them to be unnoticed I would feel
like right lesbians come conspicuous
yeah be like good we're in line but then
maybe it would be so obvious and on
point like oh yeah you would never
expect it would be like oh that's a you
you know that lesbian woman she's also a
time traveler nobody's doing all that
you know that's a lot mm-hmm
you know nobody thought that much yeah
yeah that I'm just unrealistic well you
gotta have I mean I can't a man I'm like
time travel beans are always partying
you know doing [ __ ] Woodward I wish I
was gay I wish I wish I was gay and I
wish I knew more gay people man
yeah oh yeah man my buddies to be gay
and uh and we worked at AA
we were Busboys yeah oh it was a sales
and drove into an embankment yeah so our
IP actually and he um but he was like
the first gay guy I ever met you know
and he was a boxer too and he was
Italian and he uh yeah and dude he was
like the toughest guy ever noon we were
both Busboys hmm and [ __ ] I don't know
we're talking we're talking about gay
time time travel yeah he would have told
me that's a thing another thing gay a
lot of gay men I find if you tell me of
a secret then they want to know about it
you know but because they think it's
gonna be that you're gay and then you
can be buddies you know but if the gay
if the secret is I'm from the future
that'd be like [ __ ] you know about this
you know kind of mean so I think so in
short Einstein is a time traveler I mean
how do you know that much have that big
of a different of scope one brain of
billions of people the odds that but
that's not one of the billion that's how
you explain it right or brain he's got
just like Isaac Newton Isaac Newton this
guy was so [ __ ] smart
he literally invented calculus calculus
did not exist until an apple hit this
[ __ ] on his bush he asked goofy
looking at air Wow and he's like bro
what the [ __ ] is gravity like why did
that Apple fall nobody ever even thought
about that they're just like oh we oh
you know here's the ground yeah just
walk around on it and he's the first
dude was like no like why does [ __ ] fall
to the earth right you know wow that's
fast
then he made calculus is the math as to
what he created to support it and
calculus you know everyone's like Oh
[ __ ] calculus is coming up that's the
hardest [ __ ] to learn but that
[ __ ] like no I made it that
when I was like 22 I made all that's a
recipe yes some hverir in the kitchen
dang dude imagine yeah so that's
interesting then so his whole thing was
okay at that point in time you could
watch something and then you could
figure out the stuff behind it like why
does so why let me make out yeah I think
he was like the the father of physics
basically he invent am i I'm you know
yeah and and and just a disclaimer for
all the physicists for all the
scientists watching this who are talking
about what an ignorant [ __ ] [ __ ] I
am yeah
I'm an ignorant [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah
all they've got some things wrong there
yeah and if you think I'm ignorant
I am yeah so yeah someone's working on
an exposed video right now about how
Isaac taking Isaac Newton invented
calculus is Nazi propaganda um I'm
trying to think about Isaac Newton but
here's the thing so you know I bet time
travel though if I had really had to
think about it to have that different
one super brain as you're saying like if
some guy came in right now and said hey
what you guys don't realize is like
maybe it's a guy wrote the book that
like your feelings are connected to your
muscles and there's this simple little
exercise or this met this equation that
we don't even realize it could take us
to a whole new level of how to exist
oh damn boy yeah okay Isaac st. Laurent
bro he might have been a dang lady now
this could he could have been a dang
lesbian you know I think bro all right
yeah why are all these geniuses have the
baldness hair because man you gotta have
that [ __ ] Einstein bomb ass hair Wow and
that's like a lady's co2 in it
yeah it is bro it's pretty [ __ ] it is a
nice coat huh dude he's got the best
clothes to rub York on my face
what I tell you this guy's a smart
[ __ ]
I think he was in Sigma Epsilon dude are
you sure that guy's crazy what was the
enterprise everybody is a genius but if
you judge a fish by its ability to climb
a tree it will live it's whole life
believing it's stupid like that in that
take that in for a minute I don't people
make up quotes by the way this is the
thing people would feel like no Albert
Einstein said this and then you gotta
take it almost like a lot of impact but
it's just some kid like fifth grader
yeah
imagination is more important than
knowledge I remember he said that I
think and that's true in his case
because of the thought experiment that
was my favorite thing I remember I saw
they have it at Disney World when I was
a kid and we ate a little bit of you
know acid I don't know there's that
awesome it was awesome dude and dude
I'll tell you this when you're on acid
bruh Japanese people are the most
welcoming I'll say that by far oh well I
guess they don't they don't make them
very many assumptions about what they
expect right they don't go into life it
they don't have a ton of expectation
like Oh white people are just [ __ ]
crazy and I don't understand anything
he's saying anyway because we're there's
a language barrier but we interact with
every group that night and by far the
most genteel and accepting were Japanese
the Japanese oh I like that you're
talking about that you were there in
Japan oh no no we're in Orlando far but
yeah I think it's time travel man oh
when you yeah you gotta meet people then
when you're on acid see I've never had a
good experience on acid I've tried it
like five times and every time I just
get stuck in my head and I get super
anxious and I cannot allow myself like I
forced myself to stay grounded and I
never really let myself float up mm-hmm
I force like myself to be anchored and
so it's a constant pole late to the time
to lift but trying to roll roll to the
ground so I have problem with
drugs in general because I don't like
like you said yes I guess it's a control
thing yeah maybe when you said that I
like I want to live but I'm staying
like I'm anchored that's what it may
mean if I'm it originally I could relate
that same feeling that's how I get
sometimes whenever I've done that and
man I just I wish I could be like out
here like this but I just can't for some
reason I just can't like let go of
myself enough because I'm just if I do
what will happen yeah it's scary and I'm
afraid of changing yeah or losing my
mind or something or just actually you
know what it is is like I'm off yeah I'm
afraid of just being in a different
state of mind it's so weird
yeah even with weed I can't enjoy weed
because I have the same exact reaction
yeah I hear ya but I wish I like this
yeah me too I was going like that I wish
I got high and [ __ ] you know ate a
couple ice cream scoops off of
somebody's [ __ ] back you know oh yeah
put a couple [ __ ] scoops on your
cousin [ __ ] Lance and I'm right you
know and it's [ __ ] is that our weeds
get laughs yeah I wish I could be more
fun I wish that's it that's all it is to
it let me show you a couple of things
we're running low on time oh yeah our I
got a couple of videos I went through
real quick
have you running low on time what if
Einstein heard that dude I said I be
like sorry dude be like the book he
picked the biggest contrary ever excuse
me dude time is really just an illusion
[Music]
he actually has places to go dude
yeah do you really huh yeah I sense like
it's [ __ ] illusion doc yes and sure
you do show you a chart that shows you
you do yeah
did you know that you can bend space and
time with a pencil through the piece of
paper and travel through space yeah
people like [ __ ] you really need to go
to that meeting yeah like I got beans of
time do you think so people [ __ ]
imagine how much people hated him
probably some people in the scientific
community people thought he was [ __ ]
he was very people were very skeptical
and that's in his community they were
like this guy is a [ __ ] lunatic
right and then and then when he was
working on his theory of relativity hmm
there was some other guy that started
work and he went and did a talk about it
and he's like guys look at this [ __ ] I'm
working on it's insane and everyone's
like yeah yeah whatever
but one guy was like I think he's on to
something
well I'm gonna try to beat him to it
because he wasn't finished with this
theory
so this [ __ ] start now they
start racing each other
to try to figure out the theory of
relativity to like put it all together
yeah and but I stink Einstein beat him
damn but the movie about it yeah there's
a great documentary on Netflix it's so
amazing but the other guy was like you
know I think he forfeit he's like you
know what dude like it's your it's your
glory Wow but they were close they were
like figured out at the same time dude
like science race bro crazy that's an
idiot Tony Stewart [ __ ] right there boy
that's some Jeff Gordon brought mean
that's ya when you were being science
doing a lot of science and at a high
speed
what are you any a time traveler
yeah imagine running really fast like
Carl Lewis but also doing science in
your head right what are you your time
traveler yeah or an alien yeah a
time-traveling alien probably I don't
know if they do you think they have that
no well if you're nailing you can travel
time dude time you're cuttin you know I
gotta be in BC in half an hour you know
yeah I gotta put down these flights now
that's granted in other words yeah
because you know what Einstein figured
out is that time-travel Israel because
of the red and did he really yes time
travel is real but you can't go
backwards you can only go ahead of time
I think you figured out that when you go
the speed of light or when you approach
the speed of light
time travels slower like you saw did you
see uh what's that movie called that we
loved it's not inception but the time of
the spotless mind I do love that one
base one that Nolan Rho interstellar
interstellar you see that
with Jodie Foster no that's Conterra is
another great [ __ ] one that one is
similar that's the that's what their
relativity how she comes back and
there's all that static remember that
yes
that's based on science because she was
gone for them immediately dan why do I
feel he doesn't know about science the
major it drops into the water and to
everyone yeah it looks like it was
immediate but she [ __ ] went the speed
of light and came back and she was gone
that actually doesn't make sense
I got a watch again contact alright you
know what's good um Danny should have
cut me off you know what's good is uh
I'm trying to think of what maybe I saw
that was really good oh I like Finding
Neverland and I like um wait with Johnny
Depp you like Finding Neverland yeah
it's an old movie about I don't know
wait now because I've all I've got in my
mind is leaving Neverland yeah this is
we're finding it different movie and I'm
trying to think actually there's a lot
of good movies man I shouldn't talk
started talking about that
what do you find Walt it's interesting
that there's a Finding Neverland and
others a leaving Neverland dude and they
essentially we're also talking about
[ __ ] time travel because that's what
maybe that's what it is but dude if
somebody's here a long time you know I'm
here from you know prove it well that's
what I'd say okay so what would they do
so if they just pull out a [ __ ] you
know if I watch I know was theirs out of
their eyes yeah and or it would be dope
they're not gonna have dick it's still
gonna be us though you think well if
they come from the future they must have
some dope technology there'd be like
here good point they like here if you
really need to prove it you'd be like
tomorrow Trump's gonna tweet out that he
is suck he tried once tried second his
own dick but it wasn't long enough right
and then the next day car okay and
you're like wall dude proven done that
would be crazy yeah yeah somebody can do
something as specific as that tweet
prediction yeah done I'm come Paulette I
know you gotta leave soon so I'm gonna
show you one video I have a bunch here
that I wanted to show you okay and what
are the videos about here you do this
home videos I mean yeah these are my
favorite videos of the past like month
or so I'm gonna give you a choice we
only have time for once
you decide okay okay we got the the best
man passes out during wedding okay I saw
that one okay good that one [ __ ] hurt
my feelings dude his face hit the ground
so hard bro
god it made me want to get married
actually it's an ex I think I am
assuming he was just drunk because not
everyone's curious so let me just you
know what [ __ ] junk and media they're
gonna claim this whole podcast the next
one is our Kelly recruits people do his
cult during a live show this is my this
is one of the best things ever let's see
that then I would like to see that okay
I would like we got a herb in this show
up in a couple of whites and yeah shots
in Ethiopia like to come back weird
[Music]
[Music]
you looked at the camera like did I
really say that [ __ ] like I think is it
tomorrow right there my token let me go
back anything the beaut
to the mall go back go to the mall yeah
I've watched this every time I thought
he said go to the mall we play one more
time do you money
[Music]
wait hold the [ __ ] and the mall is the
only place you'd meet somebody in a
foreign country you don't know other
places get mall come to the mom he was
like the beautiful I don't hear the be
wait hold on now this look at spider-man
in the background you see that guy -
wait hold on hold on
I hear the biggest spider-man oh my god
that guy's from the future what'd you
guys hear back there you guys here what
are you here cuz I heard comes with it
go Dan Ian Zak I
I heard the mall thing too I don't get
the context but it does sound like it's
the context that's where he goes to Mean
Girls
I heard mall - what am i joking minutes
I didn't hear beautiful mean I think I
would have heard it but I've heard it
before I would I just didn't hear it
let's go one more time do you mind we in
BRE it sounded like wonderful time
wonderful I shoulda asked you I regret
the only good ears in here probably
we're on man he's growing a baby enter
there's no way our hearings all accurate
[ __ ] here we just throne
all I can hear now is come to them why
they're beautiful I because the
background singers saying America so
maybe he's like so beautiful I can see
that too America the Beautiful yeah I
could see him saying that
wow man he did that huh I've watched
this face here he's like did I really
say that I shouldn't watch shots is that
me is there something is there anything
more romantic may I ask you
I don't ask a woman if she's got her
shots not if she's about to travel long
distance yeah and if you're gonna take
her somewhere
I think it's he's thinking of others
that's nice but he's thinking sex yeah
he's thinking I'm you'll be my dungeon a
little for yeah when we get you in
America and that's where you go forever
so there's another short one I know
you're on the time constraint I'm really
fast this was really good we're gonna
end it right after this I'm up in Orange
County
this is the same [ __ ] video okay this
is the last one come all
watch out for corn on top of
demonstration which I got doing it name
it's a lurker on the tangler cover uh
let me get that hitter on him all the
time I think the guy in the [ __ ] is
the one that's so sorry the white guy I
don't know the guy who's [ __ ] I
don't know what this is do one guy's
black and one guy's white plate what
were the guys [ __ ] it sounds like
the black I said sorry no no it's the
guy that's beeping it says sorry right
one more time
it sounds like the [ __ ] I don't like you
said come to the mall I have so many
more but you gotta go
I'll save more please bro this is what
this is what we do all day you have you
do other [ __ ] but we gotta be like right
there you write jokes you [ __ ] little
entertain real people you like travel I
don't do any of that yeah well you got
this bro I'll trade you a couple months
for that video good assume that guy
looks like yeah like Dom he's at an
audition
might have been he got the job alright
this one's gonna trip you out the [ __ ]
out
black guys get it they'll get they know
how they want things done if you're in
urinals so this dude one time beat on
the wall next to me is like a man let me
get a courtesy flush man let me get
Curtis if flutter [ __ ] I was doing
number two and he was like oh let me get
that Curtis it he wasn't even in there
that long but he was in his and I was in
mine dude another way he was [ __ ] he
was also probably [ __ ] opium for a long
time but I wanted that man that's some
same but guys they control the
environment mmm you know in it you know
what are you doing new fun do you get up
no courtesy flushes you've been sitting
in there too long you know I'm starting
to feel uncomfortable because the smell
oh wow that lady's getting into that
what is it Lobster
okay well Thanksgiving lobster anything
could be yeah but you know just because
the water splash in your ass you got to
stand up you probably had paper on the
we eat it was just the scent he didn't
want anymore
he said you stand up to flush because
the [ __ ] water will splash on your balls
in [ __ ] um I probably stayed right there
dude I got pretty nervous
yeah you don't [ __ ] around you're like
well I'd never really talked to a I
never talked to a white man or a black
man while I was taking a [ __ ] yeah no
man sorry and I don't really talk about
[ __ ] around the baby yeah he's gonna be
doing plenty of that this is like Janita
and the Giant Peach I feel like that
Lobster has like Down syndrome you can't
eat that man this is unbelievable
where's this lady from you might be
Jamaican like a thirty-minute but that
is it really that Lobster yeah oh wow 30
minutes it's called a podcaster eating
with Q No
we made a video about her on her she's
awesome huh yeah she's a [ __ ] legend
there's actually a hole what we actually
show you the durant nod watch her she's
cute too
she looks good she doesn't hair and
everything you just leave when you're
ready because at this point it's it's
1253 oh yeah I gotta leave yeah I don't
want because then I could suck you in
here dude this is awesome man thank you
got someone you got to come back again
soon because I got more videos to show
you how much more times that baby that
bun got only three months months less
than three months now June 6
I'm excited I am I feel very happy about
it and I almost I don't even like
admitting that to myself that's how
[ __ ] up I am I'm like dude you can't
feel happy about this right that's kind
of one of the cool things about
childhood it's like it's okay to feel
positive about this yeah exactly great
yeah because if you don't because if you
don't start to I think you know look at
some of that or if we don't start to
look at those kind of moments where it's
like it's yeah well I'm not feeling how
about this even though I know I probably
want to yeah and I'm not finding a way
to be that way yeah then that's where we
don't break the chain of like right you
know yeah or not that are just those
those weird feeling that song game yeah
I think I don't know man this should I
go to like 12 step programs that's where
I learned you know a lot of that kind of
thinking and stuff and for me it's been
helpful cuz I never had any thoughts
like that at all I was [ __ ] in love
you know and now but there's a whole new
mental universe yeah that you got to
discover yeah it's it's so true bruh
there's really there's like different
steps of the mental maturity and you got
it
like you got to build the scaffold
people there's people that like fully
and [ __ ] lightened yeah
like for real walk so the other [ __ ]
nuts but they're they like understand
everything alright I'm not I'm gonna let
you go okay but Theo van calm if you're
not convinced fry this they he's a the
funniest [ __ ] dude you're gonna watch
then go away oh and you guys tomorrow
yeah we got hot ones coming on tomorrow
watch that guy's eyes I was like with a
[ __ ] Sean why don't why didn't that come
out first because that's how I do all my
research for my guests I just watch hot
ones oh really yeah he's the best
researcher at him and pretend I'm like
dude always watch hot ones for 20
minutes yeah he went deep dude he has
he's yeah he knew a lot of stuff nice
guy - he's the best fun he's so good at
his job he is and he has a very unique
tone when he's talking and asking
questions yeah you know he's really good
at letting the guests shine he kind of
was like and I mean it says a compliment
he brief wrapped up the show three times
ready he's like Charlie Brown said Oh
insult I mean I wouldn't say Charlie
Brown I would say Charlie beige you know
yeah you know no I love Sean you know
Sean knows I love him no of course he
does he's just Charlie's like he's let's
let's let you know okay we'll see you
later so so Yvonne doctor go get some
[ __ ] tickets for Christ's sake go
listen to his podcast this past weekend
or two no offence on Netflix where I say
show in person that's it yeah all the
stolen Netflix is kind of okay but you
know the new experience that the club is
a lot of fun people come out it's a lot
of good people - I'm sure I think you
were testing out material probably at
The Comedy Store you told a while story
about like your brother trying to [ __ ]
you or something
oh yeah but that was a wild crazy and I
was but yeah well set yeah sex I don't
know I say that yeah you don't say
[ __ ] I as I said but it was Fannie's
a great guy doesn't reason I worked in a
free business still got a woody don't
work with this would go watch him guys
thank you for watching we will be back
and next went Wednesday with low blow mo
guys that's exciting that'll be fun so
we'll see you guys then thank you guys
appreciate you god bless see you next
week have a great week
good
then cut it off
[Music]
[Music]